david anthony
andrew amos conservative
twenty four thousand one hundred
[Music]
one hundred and four sir david amos
winning his third election in 1992
one of parliament's longest-serving mps
and one of its best loved and always a
winner with his voters
this time i was the 34th marginal seat
against the background of an economic
slump for two years and a game we win
but i'm humble about it and i just thank
all those constituents who voted for me
again i must be doing something right i
don't know what it is called but call it
the mystery of life and i think it works
quite well
a constituency mp fast and foremost sir
david served from the back benches for
almost four decades a great loss for
parliament and for south end
david and i came into the house of
commons on the same day in 1983. i've
known him and loved him as a member of
parliament as a colleague ever since he
was a devout and devoted man he was the
kindest of people he spent his entire
life
dedicated his life trying to work for
people and animals
which was another of his great causes
and his loss is absolutely tremendous
never a minister instead sir david
dedicated himself to his constituents
his roman catholic faith and causes
close to his heart
his death a tragedy that will affect
many across parliament and at home my
heart goes out to sir david's wife
to his children his wider family his
staff and all of his friends and
colleagues
today is a dark and a shocking day
the more so because
heartbreakingly we've been here before
so much of what we see in politics is
all about this place but really an mp's
work is often unseen in their
constituency
and sir david was an mp who devoted
himself to the people he served that
this service cost him his life is
utterly shocking and devastating and
that it comes just five years after the
murder of labour mp joe cox is almost
incomprehensible
and raises serious questions
about the security of mps
constituency work a key part of the job
it's not supposed to be dangerous he has
been killed serve his constituents i
never thought i would have that phone
call again and it was the tragic news
today i'm in shock and p's are in shock
right across all political parties the
one thing this that i could tell you
know we're united in our thoughts for
david his family
and everyone who knew him and the one
thing we do know
nothing will stop democracy in a toxic
time for politics david a man just
trying to get on with the job
whatever people think of us we all try
to do the best we possibly can for our
constituents and
some of us succeed up the ministerial
ladder some of us aren't interested in
that some of us just want to be good
back benches and i think that was david
and he did it absolutely brilliantly and
he certainly didn't deserve this neither
did his family and i my heart goes out
to them right children have you all
finished yes
a committed constituency mp sir david
was knighted in 2015 for political and
public service but above all else he was
a husband and a father of five
a public servant and a dedicated family
man to
beth rigby sky news